bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débats et de
reportage 90 minutes pour donner du sens
à l'actualité grâce à nos invités et à
toute la rédaction de Public Sénat et
voici le sommaire de ce 5 février
François baayrou relaxé dans l'affaire
des assistants parlementaires européens
du MoDem la fin d'une procédure longue
de 7 ans le tribunal a dit non seulement
que je n'étais pas en cause dans cette
affaire mais qu'il n'y avait pas de
système qu'il n'y avait pas
d'enrichissement personnel le président
du MoDem pourrait-il faire son retour au
gouvernement comment pèse-t-il sur le
second quinena Macron Gabriel Atal
a-t-il forcément envie de voir revenir
un tel poids lourd on en débat dans une
minute et puis pour notre second thème
volontairement décalé de l'actualité du
jour cette question comment enseigner
l'histoire à l'heure où les professeurs
deviennent aussi des cibles comment
parler de la Choa en plein conflit
Israël ramas qui ose encore montrer des
caricatures de Mahomed pour expliquer la
laïcité et puis quels arguments trouv
pour contrer les extrémistes de tout
bord sur les réseaux sociaux l'histoire
sous pression au pluriel ce sera dans
tris qu4 d'heure mais d'abord l'attente
de la liste des nouveaux ministres du
gouvernement àal c'est l'heure des
dernières tractations Fabien
REER voilà bientôt un mois qu'il est à
la tête d'un gouvernement incomplet 14
ministres nommés le 11 janvier autour de
Gabriel Attal mais aucun ministre
délégué ni secrétaire d'état et
plusieurs portefeuilles laissés en
carence la santé les transports ou
encore le logement qui traverse pourtant
une crise profonde c'est très
particulier c'est le signe d'un d'une
gestion très autoritaire et très
centralisatrice de la part d'Emmanuel
Macron ce sera réparé dans les jours
voir même les heures qui qui viennent
euh ce n'est pas un bon signe pour le
fonctionnement normal de nos
institutions de la 5e République la
deuxième vague du remanement devra aussi
contenter l'allié centriste d'Emmanuel
Macron le modem de François berou relaxé
aujourd'hui dans l'affaire des
assistants parlementaires il n'avait pas
caché son mécontentement après la
première mouture du gouvernement à tal
qui ne compte pour l'instant qu'un seul
ministre modem Marc feno à l'agriculture
des centristes échaudés par les appels
du pied d'Emmanuel Macron au LR après la
nomination de Rachida Dati à la culture
d'autres prises de guerre à droite
pourrai suivre ça changera pas la donne
c'estàdire que même s'il trouve je pas
un sénateur une sénatrice lire qui
rentre au gouvernement comme ce ne sera
pas sur un poste très visible entre
guillemets puisque les 14 ont déjà été
nommés ça ne changera pas la donne ni au
sein du Sénat ni au sein du groupe des
Républicains reste le dossier oué à
Castera empêtré dans une polémique sans
fin après ses propos controversés sur
l'école publique la ministre de
l'Éducation nationale également en
charge du sport pourra-t-elle rester au
gouvernement la suite du casting
gouvernemental est attendue d'ici
demain le remanimement la relaxe de
François Baayou la première motion de
censure contre Gabriel àal voilà les les
trois grands thèmes dont on débat tout
de suite avec jean-garic bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes historien présent du
Comité d'histoire parlementaire et
auteur de ce livre jours heureux quand
les Français rêvent ensemble publiés aux
éditions Paillot Stéphane zumsek bonsoir
et bienvenue vous êtes le directeur du
département Opinion à l'institut de
sondage Ipsos Jean-Sébastien Ferjou
bonsoir et bienvenue fondateur et
directeur d'Atlantico j'accueille
également Mathieu croissandau bonsoir
mathieuons bienven à vous éditorialiste
politique Gabriel Atal nommé le 9
janvier Jean garig un premier ministre
a-t-il déjà attendu aussi longtemps
avant de d'avoir son gouvernement en
complet en quelque sorte la réponse est
non euh ça tient à plusieurs facteurs
qui sont d'abord la difficulté à trouver
euh des volontaires euh pour participer
ça fait moins rêver euh de de devenir
ministre délégué ou secrétaire d'État
oui et puis quand vous êtes dans la
situation actuelle avec euh un
gouvernement majorité relative un
président impopulaire c'est quand même
un défi qui n'est pas forcément qui qui
n'intéresse pas forcément beaucoup de
monde euh et 2èe facteur euh on en a
parlé à propos de François baayerou bah
il faut trouver un équilibre avec les
partenaires de de la majorité y compris
d'ailleurs au sein de Renaissance où
l'ile gauche pour l'instant est assez
peu représenté au gouvernement il faut
trouver du Modem François Baayou demande
au moins trois autres secrétaires d'État
au ministre délégué de l'horizon pour
pour pour Édouard Philippe et puis il
faut trouver la parité homme-femme donc
voilà une équation enfin plusieurs
équations qui expliquent que ça ne soit
pas forcément très rapide ouis Stéphan
je pense pas que les les Français
attendent avec une
impatience énorme le la nomination de
ses ces futurs et nouveaux ministre mais
ils vont ils vont quand même partir
c'est pas un cadeau ils vont partir de
loin pour gagner en popularité c'est un
peu le le syndrome du ban de touche
est-ce que vous le vous le l'analyser
comme ça avant de gagner en popularité
il faut gagner en notoriété si c'est
possible et on voit bien que vous n'avez
qu' demandé à n'importe quel français
dans la rue de citer plus que 3 qu 5
ministres en règle générale là il y a
une nomination récente évidemment les
gens ne connaissent que les quelques
poids lourd les quelques tenurs de de la
vie donc ça ça c'est pour les 11 entre
guillemets je Guill super ministres qui
on des des portefeuill élargi et trois
ministres délégés déjà ceux-là sont sont
pas forcément identifiés donc il y a pas
d'attente particulière sur cette seconde
vague de de de nomination bien sûr mais
en Revan ça reste toujours un exercice
un peu compliqué pour pour un pour un
nouveau Premier ministre la première la
première livraison a été relativement
bien accueillie Gabriel Atal c'est
quandême le premier des quatre premier
ministres de d'Emmanuel Macron qui
arrive connu et populaire donc rien que
ça il disposait d'un d'un avantage
comparatif par rapport à ces trois
prédécesseurs maintenant les enjeux mais
vous l'évoquiez c'est qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire de l' gauche de ces ministres qui
avaient manifesté leur mécontentement
est-ce qu'ils vont être purgés est-ce
qu'ils vont être rattrapés rattrapés en
parti ou pas et il y a évidemment la
question du model et il y a la question
on en parlera tout à l'heure de la
ministre de l'Éducation nationale mais
il y a pas d'attente particulière ce que
l'on peut dire c'est que ce nouveau
gouvernement a été plutôt bien reçu et
pu exactement l'arrivée de gabrielal
amatigon a été bien acceptée bien perçu
et en tout cas n pas pass c'est dans
l'indifférence de l'opinion publique si
si josis une question un peu provoque ça
sert à quoi un ministre Jean Sébastien
Ferjou ben alors je suis totalement
d'accord qu'il n'y a aucune attente je
pense dans le pays personne n'est
suspendu à son poste de télévision pour
savoir qui va être nommé ministre si
nous parce que on est passionné de
politique et nos téléspectateurs aussi
oui et encore mais en revanche on
devrait s'y intéresser malgré tout mais
pas tant pour le casting ou pour les
raisons qui ont été évoquées qui font
partie intégrant de l'équation
incontestablement sur la parité sur
l'équilibre politique au sein de la
majorité sur peut-être une meilleure
représentation du territoire aussi hein
François baayroui il y a pas un ministre
qui est originaire du sud de la loi et
on voit que là dans le gouvernement
resserré il y a essentiellement des
ministres Parisiens
alorsobjectif dans l'absolu mais quand
même c'est bien d'avoir des relais à
différents endroits ne serit-ce que pour
prendre le pou l'opinion mais surtout
moi je crois regardez ce qui s'est passé
la semaine dernière en pleine crise des
agricultures de l'agriculture pardon on
voit une administration qui présente un
plan de gestion de l'eau complètement
délirant complètement à l'encontre de ce
que le premier ministre était en train
de dire et donc je crois que le critère
finalement mais auquel ne répondra
probablement pas le nouveau casting
c'est d'avoir des ministres à poigne des
gens qui savent s'imposer imposer leur
volonté à leur administration parce
qu'on peut pas mais est-ce qu'il faut
être super ministre pour ça c'est pour
ça que je posais la question de faut-il
faut un périmètre très important il faut
une expérience il faut connaître il faut
connaître l'appareil d'État on ne
s'improvise pas euh ministre il faut
avoir un vrai sens un véritable sens
politique parce que il faut articuler
justement l'administration les enjeux
techniques et les attentes des Français
et il faut savoir encore une fois
imposer son autorité à son
administration mais comme on est très
démagogue et qu'en plus on a restreint
le nombre de conseillers par exemple
ministériel mais c'est absurde un
ministre délégué ou un secrétaire d'État
en droit à très peu de conseillers il
est irréaliste d'imaginer qu'il puisse
s'imposer donc quand on est pris entre
ce qui vient de Bruxelles et ce que
l'administration française continue à
faire dans son coin souvenez-vous quand
François Hollande a voulu faire son choc
de simplification juste cet exemple là
vous savez le principe était devenu que
si l'administration ne répond pas à une
demande un permis de construire ou autre
le principe est pas de réponse c'est oui
et ben l'administration qu'est-ce
qu'elle a fait elle a inventé plus
d'exception à la règle que la règle donc
elle a dit non non non oui le principe
vaut mais à l'exception de ces je sais
plus combien 642000 cas donc voilà donc
on a besoin de ministres qui sachent
tenir leur administration Mathieu interv
la vraie question c'est pourquoi faire
parce que un gouvernement non mais un
gouvernement ça c'est vrai que c'est un
subtile équilibre de sensibilité au sein
d'une majorité mais les sensibilités
qu'est-ce qu'elles veulent faire c'est
quoi la sensibilité au-delà des des
caprices des barons François baayerou
d'un côté Édouard Philippe de l'autre qu
quelle ligne va défendre François
baayerou quelle ligne va défendre
Édouard Philippe quelle ligne va
défendre l'elle gauche pour l'instant
ils se sont tous écrasés il y en a qu'un
qui a décidé c'est Emmanuel Macron et
d'une certaine façon ce qu'on va voir là
dans la première mouture du gouvernement
Gabriel hatal s'est fait imposer des
ministres la plupart sont restés en tout
cas dans les grands ministères il s'est
même fait imposer son directeur de
cabinet ce qu'on va voir là aussi c'est
si d'une certaine façon il arrive à
faire des choix et à en discuter et à
remporter avec le président le cas se
pose notamment sur la la fameuse
question d'Amélie oua Castera dont on
sait qu'elle est plutôt soutenue par
l'Élysée alors que matigon se verrait
bien la cornérisé ou en tout cas pas
forcément l'exfiltré du gouvernement
mais peut-être lui retirer S et et là ça
va être un test de voir au fond qui
commande alors on va en reparler
évidemment longuement à la fois de
François Baayou ça relaxe et puis du cas
Amélie ou Cass mais d'abord il y a alors
je sais pas quel termey peut-être ce
mythe du gouvernement resserré on va en
parler tout de suite avec Steve Jourdain
qui nous rejoint sur le plateau de de
sens public bonsoir Steve bienvenue à
vous est-ce qu'on va enfin voir ce
gouvernement resserré promis par
Emmanuel Macron il faut garder espoir il
faut garder espoir Tomas c'est pas la
première fois effectivement que le chef
de l'État nous le premier rappelez-vous
le 12 mars 2017 le candidat Emmanuel
Macron est sur le plateau de TF1 il fait
la promesse suivante j'aurais à nommer
un Premier ministre et un gouvernement
je constituerai un gouvernement de 15 ms
maximum très ramassé avec des personnes
de la société civile et des personnes du
monde politique venant de la gauche du
centre et de la droite au mois d'avril
le candidat devient président de la
République et la promesse n'est pas
vraiment suivie des faits non entre
avril entre avril entre 2017 et
aujourd'hui on a navigué entre 30 et 40
ministres le gouvernement borne
intronisé en juillet 2022 contre 41
membres total en plus hein de la
première ministre 16 ministres de plein
exercice 15 ministres délégués 10
secrétaires d'État on a déjà vu beaucoup
plus resserré dans l'histoire de la 5e
République alors ben on regarde un peu
dans le rétroviseur lesquels alors le la
moyenne sous la 5e République c'est
33,9 ministres je vous l' fait 34
ministres on va faire une petite 34 on
arrondit le record du gouverement dit
qu'ils ont pas forcément beaucoup de
pouvoir alors un 0,9 de ministres on le
record le plus compact de l'histoire de
la 5e c'est le gouvernement Fillon 1 19
membres au total bon il avait duré qu'un
mois entre mai et juin 200 7 mention
spéciale aussi au gouvernement Pompidou
entre 62 et 66 georgees Pompidou dirige
une équipe de 25 membres le record du
gouvernement qui qui est le moins
resserré de l'histoire de la 5mc bon on
le voit j'ai votre texte donc je peux
dire Michel rard gouvernement Michel
recard effectivement entre 88 et 91 on
compte 48 personnes autour du Premier
ministre socialiste est-ce que c'est si
important d'avoir un gouvernement
resserré ben c'est là toute la question
effectivement à chaque reménement vous
l'avez dit on nous promet un
gouvernement resserré un gouverement
gouvernement d'attaque un gouvernement
pleinement mobilisé garanti sans gras
derrière tout ça il y a l'idée qu'un
gouvernement coûte de l'argent au
contribuable contribuable et dans le
contexte actuel et bien il faut faire
des économies ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que le budget de fonctionnement d'un
gouvernement bah c'est pas énorme si on
compte les ministres les secrétaires
d'État les collaborateurs on arrive au
total à
172,8 millions d'euros l'année dernière
pour le gouvernement borne à titre de
comparaison les dépenses totales du
budget de l'État pour 2023 on le voit
c'est plus de 450 milliards d'euros
Thomas en gros pour 1000 € de dépenses
général on donne 12 petits centimes pour
faire fonctionner notre gouvernement on
pourra toujours dire que c'est 12
centimes de trop mais c'est peut-être
tout simplement le prix de la démocratie
au fond un ministre de plus un ministre
de moins peu importe l'important c'est
qu'il soit compétent effectivement merci
beaucoup Steve jeangar votre avis
là-dessus est-ce que il y a une part de
de de démagogie autour de cette
thématique du gouvernement resserré qu
que nous ressert d'ailleurs il y a pas
qu'Emmanuel Macron hein ses
prédécesseurs ont souvent dit les mêmes
choses en tout cas c'est un maronnier ou
un peu une arlaisienne de de la 5èe
République ça c'est c'est une certitude
mais si on regarde ce qui se passe il y
avait ces ces deux exemples d'un côté le
gouvernement Pompidou de 62 et celui de
rard en 88 vous voyez bien que le fait
que ce gouvernement Pompidou est été
resserré attestait d'une confiance que
le Président de la République avait
attribué à son à son son premier
ministre pour lui permettre d'être
vraiment un premier ministre et d'être
le chef de son gouvernement alors que le
dans le cas de de Michel recard qui
était par ailleurs très populaire et
beaucoup plus populaire que que François
mitteran on sait bien que cette
multiplicité de de de ministres avait
pour objectif non seulement de
représenter toutes les composantes du
Parti socialiste mais surtout de
paralyser tant que faire se pouvait
l'action de Michel rord ou en tout cas
de la contrecarré pas tout à fait de la
paralyser puisqu'il a quand même agi
donc on voit bien malgré tout que ça
reste quelque chose qui n'est pas
l'essentiel à mon sens l'essentiel étant
le cap que vous donnez et comme le
disait jean- Sébastien la manière dont
vous insufflez votre politique à une
administration c'est ça le au fond
l'essentiel le cap que vous que vous
donnez mais il est vrai que c'est quand
même plus facile dans un gouvernement
resserré dans un gouvernement surtout
dont le premier ministre tient
véritablement ses ses ministres or dans
la situation actuelle et avec la le
style Jupiterrien d'Emmanuel Macron on
peut craindre et c'est ce qui s'est
passé dans les gouvernements précédents
que ça soit toujours le président de la
République qui instore des des dialogues
bilatéraux avec les ministres et qu'on
cour circuite un peu trop le Premier
ministre à voir est-ce que gabrielal va
réussir précisément acquérir sa place
plus difficile pour gabrielal face aux
ministres qui sont là depuis longtemps
je pense à Bruno Le Maire qui alors dire
il une telle valse de ministre de
l'Économie avant lui que on va pas se
plaindre queil soit resté en place
longtemps justement peut-être pour tenir
cette administration plétorique on peut
aussi citer Éric dupontéti qui est resté
en place plusieurs années ça ça
complique la tâche de Gabriel Atal pour
vous je pense pas que ce soit le fait
qu'il soit là depuis longtemps qu'il
complique la Tâage de Gabriel Atal c'est
plutôt le fait que ce soit des gens qui
a une relation directe avec le
président une après qu'il soit là depuis
longtemps ou non si Emmanuel Macron
respectecter l'esprit comme la lettre de
la Constitution d'ailleurs le premier
ministre serait censé quand même diriger
l'action
du gouvernement maintenant je crois que
on est c'est quand même très démagogique
cette volonté d'avoir des des
gouvernements resserrés pourquoi parce
que d'un on l'a vu c'est un coup qui est
assez ridicule mais limite c'est même
pas tellement la question c'est parce
que cette logique là ça serait une
logique à l'américaine oui a moins de
membres du gouvernement aux États-Unis
sauf que vous avez le spoil système sauf
que vous avez le spoil
système spoil système c'est-à-dire que
quand un nouveau pouvoir un nouvelle
administration arrive aux États-Unis on
change la tête de toutes les grandes
administration et on y nomme des gens
qui partagent la vision politique de du
locataire de la Maison Blanche et donc
là vous avez besoin de moins de
ministres de moins de portefeuille
effectivement puisqu'il y a un relais
naturel à la tête des fameuses
administrations un des grands échecs de
Donald Trump d'ailleurs ayant été de ne
pas avoir il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
nominations qui n'ont jamais été faites
même après à la fin de son mandat il y
avait des gens qui n'avaient jamais été
nommés enfin des postes qui n'avaient
jamais été nommés en France c'est
différent donc il y a besoin de
politique pour s'imposer à
l'administration ou sinon il faut faire
un SPO système ce que Emmanuel Macron
avait évoqué à une époque mais qui n'a
pas fait après inventer des ministres
pour le plaisir d'inventer des ministres
pour des critères d'équilibre politique
comme vous l'évoqué dans le cadre du
gouvernement recard parce que il faut
tenir la majorité on s'en fiche des
ministres à l'écologie des crevettes ou
je ne sais quoi non mais un ministre qui
n'a pas d'administration centrale sous
son autorité est un ministre qui ne sert
à rien h c'est le cas quand même
malheureusement souvent de beaucoup de
secré sur la couleur on imagine enfin je
vois pas pourquoi Gabriel Attal et
Emmanuel Macron là pour élargir ce
gouvernement il aait chercher de nouveau
LR parce que on av le message est passé
je pense sur la la première version
resserée du du gouvernement mais
d'ailleurs ce message est passé parce
que c'est peut-être aussi ce qu'une
grande partie de l'opinion publique
française souhaite de toute façon ce que
on constate depuis quelques années et ça
s'est accéléré avec le projet de de loi
sur l'immigration de toute façon
l'opinion publique sur toute une série
de domaines notamment le régalien mais
pas que c'est fondamentalement droitisé
donc sans dire je suis pas là pour dire
que Emmanuel Macron gouverne selon les
sondages au gré des humeurs de l'opinion
en partie comme n'importe quel homme
politique évidemment mais de toute façon
tout ça a commencé le jour de la
nomination d'Édouard Philippe à matinon
enfin en presque 7 ans la stratégie n'a
jamais bougé d'un iota c'est toujours la
même chose c'est toujours du du
débauchage d'élu et ça a fonctionné
d'Edouard Philippe et Bruno Leem
évidemment qui était quand même les les
deux belles prises et et ça continue ça
continue avec Rachid hadti alors est-ce
que ce sera ce serait moins important
moins intéressant pour le gouvernement
ou pour Emmanuel Macron de le refaire là
demain si ça intervient demain mais si
réussi à reprendre un ou deux députés ma
d pourquoi s' pr au risque quand même de
fâcher alors j'ai bien compris il veut
moins utiliser le l'Assemblée nationale
plus de plus de de voix réglementair
pour Gabriel àal donc il aura peut-être
un peu moins besoin de de sa majorité
relative à l'Assemblée mais quand même
le risque de fâcher et François Baayou
et Édouard Philippe n'est pas neutre
dans dans les décions qui vont être pris
là dans vous avez raison donc il faud
qu'il agisse avec prudence mais quand on
voit l'effet notamment psychologique qui
a eu sur les l' l'arrivée de rashti au
gouvernement il y a il y a de quoi avoir
envie de refaire le coup alors ce sera
sans doute pas quelqu'un de l'équivalent
à la fois politique et en terme de de
d'image que la ministre de la Culture
mais la destruction deslr ça reste un
objectif à long terme et ça fonctionne
votre avis àdessus peut-être Mathieu sur
la destruction des je pense qu'ils sont
déjà largement détruits donc ça sera un
clou de plus dans le cercueil non juste
sur le gouvernement erré il y a juste
une petite chose c'est qu'on est quand
même complètement schizophrène en France
que on est soidisant pour des g se la
classe politique il faut faire une
équipe de choc de combat un gouvernement
série et supposant que ça plaît aux
Français et en même temps les Français
dès que le gouvernement est affiché ben
il y a toutes les clientèles qui pas
minist mon ministre j'ai pas mon
ministre j'ai pas mon ministre j'ai pas
mon ministre donc ça c'est quand même
particulier par ailleurs je rejoins
jeansébastien sur le fait que quand on a
une administration on est plus fort et
c'est sûr que ce sont surtout les
ministres qui comptent mais après on
peut il y a beaucoup de secrétariat
d'État qui ne riment à rien par le passé
et en même temps des champs de de de de
de l'actualité j'allais dire en tout cas
des thématiques du futur qui sont qui
sont pas abordé moi il y aurait un
ministre de l'intelligence artificielle
ça ne me choquerait pas d'une certaine
façon parce que c'est un enjeu qui va
être fondamental mais je mais mais en
même temps est-ce qu'on a besoin besoin
d'avoir un ministre de l'Environnement
un secrétaire d'État la biodiversité et
voilà et raffiné comme ça dans le détail
c'est pas évident il faut que ce soit
des des ministères qui a du sens surtout
mais sur le risque du débauchage je
pense qu'il a il y a un risque mineur
vous l'évoquez que les LR se fâche parce
que
M plus en situation de faiblesse et plus
ils peuvent être tentés de se rebeller
et un risque majeur c'est que l'opinion
quand même se dise que tout ça c'est du
foutage de gueule pardon mais si vous
nommez Rachid adati après Rima Abdou al
Malak en ayant en donnant l'impression
que rien n'a changé ou Gabriel Atal
après papendia en donnant l'impression
que rien n'a changé alors que ce sont
des visions de la politique profondément
différentes vous entretenez l'idée quand
même de que la parole publique n'a
aucune espèce de crédibilité et que
finalement on peut nommer bidule ou
machin ce qui compte c'est uniquement
Emmanuel Macron et que c'est quand même
un peu de la poudre au yeux et moi je je
pense que ce risque là il ne faut pas le
sous-estimer et encore plus quand on
nomme des ministres à n'importe quoi
quand on nomme des ministres à n'importe
quoi la tentation pour eux et de faire
de la communication et pendant ce
temps-là la véritable action politique
attendue par les Français elle
n'intervient pas alors on a commencé à
l'évoquer mais on va y consacrer
plusieurs minutes le le cas Amélie ouea
Castera peut-elle rester ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
des sports et des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques alors sur l'éducation
écoutez la ccrétaire fédéral de Sud
éducation elle est évidemment très
critique vis-à-vis de sa ministre de
tutelle c'était dans la manifestation du
1er février dernier ah benah c'est une
catastrophe vraiment
elle a elle a c'est une ministre qui va
qui mène une politique qui va à
l'encontre de l'intérêt du service
publicque d'éducation qui mène qui
incarne la haute bourgeoisie qui ne
comprend absolument pas ce que c'est que
le service public et l'intérêt des
élèves et des personnels nous là on est
en train de de poser la question de sa
sa démission au centre su d'éducation je
pense queon est tous d'accord pour dire
que était plus que maladroite Jean
Garing mais quand quand elle dit parce
que c'était l'une de ses prises de
parole il y a quelques joursou Cera et
je vais la citer on veut faire de moi le
symbole d'une caste privilégiée à
abattre à combattre et à abattre est-ce
qu'elle a pas tout à fait tort quand
même oui mais le problème c'est qu'elle
s'est elle-même placée dans cette
situation je veux dire que la manière
dont elle s'est défendue dont parfois
même a provoqué la la conduit justement
à incarner ce qu'elle réfute ou ou en
tout cas à cette cette incarnation qui
qui qui lui semble je dirais un jugement
a priori et et péjoratif donc c'est
quand même très compliqué de toute ça
veut dire qu'on peut on peut pas être
ministre de l'éducation nationale si on
a ses enfants dans le privé non mais
bien sûr que si bien sûr que si
d'illeurs pose la question
volontairement provocatrice euh papendia
il avait ses enfants à l'École
alsacienne non c'est c'est pas le
problème mais précisément c'est un
problème de de communication et d'
incntion elle malheureusement elle s'est
enfermée elle-même dans ce dans ce dans
ce ce problème là sachant déjà que les
syndicats d'enseignants à la base
pendant les deux quinquenas d'Emmanuel
Macron sont sont à priori hostille il
faut il faut il faut relativiser les
choses on a des opposants politiques du
côté des des syndicats mais mais il est
vrai par exemple que Gabriel Atal avait
quand même un petit peu mieux réussi à
les les amadouer c'est pas le mot mais
en tout cas à réussir à faire passer ses
idées pas pas de manière très très
comment dirais-je fluide mais enfin
c'était quand même mieux reçu là on a
quand même une difficulté et alors
d'autant plus que et c'est ça qui est
quand même très étonnant mais il y a des
explication à à cette à ce paradoxe que
il me semble que le le monde sportif lui
est plutôt derrière elle et et c'est
plutôt satisfait de de ce qu'avait été
son passage à à la jeunesse et au sport
donc on on a quelqu'un finalement qui
qui n'est pas à sa place et qui dans sa
communication a donné une image
désastreuse finalement de ce qu'elle
pourrait faire comment est-elle perçu
par l'opinion Stéphan trs bien alors
j'aurais dû poser la question
différemment en terme de je v pas parler
de popularité mais notoriété est-ce
qu'elle était
identifiée comment avant avant ce qui
elle était comme plein d'autres de ses
collègues évidemment très très peu connu
voir pas du tout connu évidemment à
partir du moment elle où elle prend ce
super ministère on en a beaucoup parlé
il y avait que 11 ministres et tout de
suite après la polémique dès le
lendemain débute et donc maintenant
évidemment tout le monde l'identifie
l'identifie à la personne qui qui qui a
des casseroles en fait parce que qu'elle
soit responsable ou pas elle a fait
preuve d'une terrible maladresse à
minima mais il y a tout le reste il y a
sa rémunération à la Fédération
Française de Tennis il y a une
éventuelle dérogation avérée ou pas
d'ailleurs pour de parcours su pour son
fils enfin il y en a tous les jours il y
a la démission du recteur en en
île-defance c'est autre chose ça je
reviendrai peut-être c'est autre chose
par que je c'est tous les jours il a des
polémiques rattachées à son nom c'est ça
le problème ça peut être unjuste dans
certain cas
é de façon né moi je sais pas quel est
l'aveniron que président de la répuique
Premier ministre lui prédise au sein du
gouvernement mais le gouvernement a une
opportunité de s'en débarrasser pour
parler clairement c'est que ce n'est pas
un poids lourd de la vie politique elle
passe pas c'est pas géralin c'est pas
Bruno le mer elle sera peut-être
maintenue mais moi je trouverais
étonnant qu'on la maintienne à un poste
de ministre de l'éducation nationale
parce que ceux qui détiennent la clé
sont les enseignants et avoir une un ou
une ministre de l'éducation nationale à
qui des enseignants ne veulent pas
parler je ne vois pas comment on tient
ça ne serait-ce qu'à court terme Jean
Sébastien Ferjou votre avis peut-être
que effectivement euh l'acceptera-t-elle
je ne sais pas mais rester ministre des
Sports et des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques à euh 160 moins de 180
jours de de de l'ouverture des Jeux
c'est peut-être pas une mauvaise idée
plutôt que de nommer quelqu'un qui
maîtrise pas les les dossiers mais
l'exfiltré de l'éducation nationale ça
peut être ça la solution mais de toute
façon oui on voit mal comment elle
pourrait avoir un bilan à la tête de ce
ministère là combien même elle serait
maintenu parce qu'Emmanuel Macron on le
sait aime résister à la pression il
suffit qu'il pense que tout le monde
veut cal S pour ça relève plus du
caprice que du sens politique mais bref
et puisque elle n'a pas su doser en fait
elle aurait pu faire de sa gave première
une transgression et assumer une forme
de transgression et de parler vrai en
disant benah écoutez la réalité ce que
vivent des milliers de parents en France
c'est cette perception qu'ils ont de
l'école publique don maintenant je ferai
tout ce qu'il est possible de faire mais
elle n'a pas fait ça elle était en
permanence sauf qu'elle a été rattrapée
par sa propre réalité les témoignages de
de de professeurs ou de parents d'élèves
duège
je garantis qu'on connaî d'autres
personnalités politiques qui ont
certainement des casseroles infiniment
plus lourdes et plus gênantes que celle
de Madame et qui s'en sortent parce
qu'ils savent en faire quelque chose ils
savent c'est c'est aussi une réalité de
communication elle n'a pas su elle en
est même arrivé imaginez-vous à dire ah
mais vous savez je ne suis pas
catholique enfin quand on est à ce
degrélà de folie furieuse en terme de
communication c'est je vois pas comment
elle peut s'en sortir de toute façon
c'est un ministère qui est cogéré par
les syndicats il faut une personnalité à
R questionut à sonste non parce qu'il y
a pas d'espoir parce que et vous le
disiez il y a deux mauvaises solutions
pour elle c'est soit finalement elle
cède à tout ce que lui demande les
syndicats pour faire oublier son mauvais
départ soit elle essaie de s'imposer
mais sauf que ça part avec tellement
tellement déjà d' priori que ça ne peut
pas marcher il faut une personnalité qui
arrive en imposant une autorité mais
quand même dans un g de velours Mathieu
pour commencer ensuite je surtout c'est
est-ce que l'école est le chantier
prioritaire de ce Ken ça fait partie en
tout cas des chantiers qui ont été c'est
devenu un sujet régalien pour le
président de la République l'été derni
Gabri a dit je l'emporte avec moi à
matigon c'est le sujet structurant
soisant du quin si c'est le cas elle
doit partir on ne peut pas laisser
concrètement quelqu'un qui n qui n'est
pas capable soit de faire preuve
d'autorité ou qui ne prouve pas par sa
compétence ou par sa capacité à lever
une forme d'enthousiasme les réformes
prioritaires elle n'est pas en mesure de
les faire donc c'est juste ça après on
verra si comme le dit Jean Sébastien le
président de la République décide de la
maintenir à son poste par entêtement
pour sauver la face sans dira long à
contrario sur la priorité qui accordé à
l'éducation et peut-être aussi sur la
marge de manœuvre de Gabriel Atal oui
sur la marge manœuvre mais surtout sur
si l'objectif c'est de réformer l'école
il faut mettre quelqu'un qui est capable
de réformer l'école aujourd'hui elle
n'est plus en situation de Jean gar oui
la l'éducation c'est la priorité de
Gabriel hatal cétait pas forcément celle
de celle d'Emmanuel Macron ça c'est la
la première chose d'où l'étonnement par
rapport à la nomination de de Madame oua
casterra je me demande si c'est pas trop
tard pour pour pour la sanctionner
précisément dans la logique qui est
celle d'Emmanuel Macron de ne pas perdre
la face et Dieu sait que c'est imp ça a
l'air important pour lui je suis pas sûr
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui aurait pu
apparaître comme une sanction immédiate
vous avez fait une faute Jean-Jacques
servant Schreber en 1974 il fait une
faute au bout d'une semaine il est
débarqué là elle fait une faute
manifestement qui est relevée par toute
la presse par par toute la classe
politique on aurait pu la sanctionner à
ce moment-là et là essayer d'appeler
quelqu'un d'autre en tout cas à à
l'éducation nationale aujourd'hui moi je
ne vois plus comme solution en me
mettant dans la psychologie d'Emmanuel
Macron que d'appeler comme ministre
délégué à l'enseignement par exemple un
une personnalité qui elle soit
susceptible d'abord de prendre un peu
plus les les les feux des projecteurs
qui a plus de sens politique et qui soit
surtout susceptible de parler avec les
syndicats c'est c'est toute la question
maintenant qui est l'iseau rare ça c'est
encore autre chose est-ce que ça
pourrait être François Baayou tiens
c'est la question qu'on va se poser
ensemble
j'y crois pas tropop j'y crois pas trop
mais bon je suis là pour ouvrir des le
champ des possibles on va dire ça comme
ça on va écouter tiens la réaction du
président du MoDem après ça relaxe dans
cette affaire d'assistant parlementaires
européens pour moi évidemment
c'est un cauchemar de cette
année qui qui vient de s'achever par une
décision sans contestation tribunal et
évidemment je pense au gâi que ça
représente au
gachi
politique puisque pendant se années nous
avons été en fait interdit de
responsabilité je pense au gâis
financier qui est très
important et je pense au gâchi humain
Mathieu on le voit on l'entend soulager
oui c'est un soulagement pour le patron
du modem qui était un peu au purgatoire
depuis 2017 un purgatoire doré certes he
sous les lambris du Commissariat au PL
rebaptisé au Commissariat au Plan quand
François Baayou il a été nommé mais
quand on se souvient quand même qu'il
démissionna du ministère de la Justice
en 2017 un mois seulement après ce
nomination alors qu'il ne faisait que
l'objet d'une ouverture d'enquête d'une
information judiciaire je veux dire
alors que le gouvernement natal
accueille aujourd'hui une ministre déjà
mise en examen on se dit quand même que
l'eau a coulé sous les pont sous les
ponts pardon du du du Nouveau Monde
soulagé donc parce qu'à 74 ans quand
même s'il avait été condamné c'était la
fin de de sa carrière politique mais ça
relaxe au bénéfice du doute n'effacera
pas quand même les dommages en terme
d'image pour pour son parti hein parce
que l'histoire retiend donc que François
Baayou fondateur et patron incontesté du
MoDem n'a donc rien vu rien su ni même
subodoré des pratiques illégales qui
valent aujourd'hui à de ces coprévenus
dont 5 € députés d'être condamné à des
peines allant de 10 à 18 mois
d'emprisonnement avec surcis à sortie
d'amende et des années d'inégibilité et
quiivalent à la formation centriste de
devoir régler une facture de 400000 €
peut-il revenir au premier plan
politique bah il en rêve mais c'est pas
certain car François baayrou n'occupe
plus tout à fait la même place dans la
galaxie masroniste qu'il y a 7 ans en
2017 il était le faiseur de roi l'allié
incontournable d'un jeune président qui
du coup lui était redevable en 2024 il
est toujours à la table des Dîn import
mais plutôt dans le rô dans le rôle
pardon du du du vieil oncle jamais
content le président l'entend davantage
qu' qu'il ne l'écoute il n'a pas suivi
ses recommandations sur la réforme des
retraites il n'a pas suivi ses
préventions sur la réforme sur le projet
de loi immigration il n'a pas suivi ses
récrimination contre la nomination de
Gabriel Atal à Matignon alors que
François baayrou avait pesé lourd dans
le choix d'Élisabeth born en 2022 per
François Baayou a même dû batailler pour
que Marc fenau le principal représentant
du MoDem conserve son portefeuille à
l'agriculture début janvier il se démène
aujourd'hui en coulisse on en parlait
pour qu'un quotat de bewist au moins
trois supplémentaires puisse figurer
dans la seconde tnée du gouvernement
alors c'est en train de se jouer en ce
moment ces dernières tractation cette
relaxe elle devrait lui permettre de
peser davantage oui on verra la liste
quand même mais c'est vrai que on en
parlait le nom de François bayerou a
circulé ce weekend depuis quelques jours
pour remplacer Amélie bouac C Cera au
ministère de l'éducation mais d'une
façon générale les centres du modem ne
sont pas d parce que ils savent que
qu'Emmanuel Macron qui a effectué un
sacré virage à droite quand même on en a
beaucoup parlé a quand même beaucoup
moins besoin de qu'il y a 7 ans quand à
Gabriel hatal et ben il prévoit de
gouverner par décret essentiellement ce
qui lui évitera d'avoir à passer des
compromis avec des alliés peut-être
devenu Réal ouais Stéphan zumseg c'est
un peu la même question je pose à chaque
fois pardon mais la popularité de de
François non surtout à quel point peut-
peut-il être utile à Emmanuel Macron là
dans les trois prochaines années de de
son second quinté moi je pense qu'il a
une carte à jouer je sais pas ce que ça
donnera dans lesffits évidemment mais je
trouve qu'il y a quand même un côté
miroir inversé ou en tout cas
complémentarité avec la la personnalité
du président de la République euh alors
idéologiquement il vient ok de l'UDF une
sorte de démocratie chrétienne même si
il a abandonné ses c'est c'est c'estes
marqueurs de droite mais
euh pas de par son âge
mir parce que parce que je notamment sur
le sur le profil enfin on voit bien dans
les enquêtes d'opinion si vous voulez
que les Français veulent de plus en plus
de consensus et de moins en moins de
brutalité dans la façon d'exercer le
pouvoir bon Emmanuel Macron s'est
distingué par son sa présidence ses
présidence verticale quelqu'un qui est
un peu plus rond qui suscite un peu plus
de dialogue de qui cherche à susciter le
consensus pourrait avoir un rôle je
parle évidemment de Françis Baou en tout
cas dans dans le cœur de la macronie
autour du président de la République pas
comme premier ministre pas forcément
comme ministre mais et je pense aussi
qu'il il aurait de par son profil
j'insiste il est issu des territoires
enfin des pirénées atlantiques ses
parents été agriculteurs il a été
enseignant il a été élu d'une ville de
province euh il a toujours été
idéologiquement en faveur des choses
qu'attendent les Français c'estàdire une
poursuite de la décentralisation et on
peut raisonnblement supposer que
reconnaître en tout cas que le bilan de
la du président de la République dans
ces domaines-là n'est pas n'est pas
magistral de la même manière qu'il s'est
toujours prononcé pour euh une
modification du scrutin notamment lors
des élections législatives là aussi des
choses qui sont demandés par l'opinion
publique en étant moins brutal et plus
accommodant en tout cas que Président il
a peut-être une carte à jouer comme
complément pas comme premier ministre
mais en en réintégrant le cœur du
réacteur de la macronie et c'était pas
le cas jusqu' prés an puisqu'il avait
disparu un petit peu des radars depuis
2017 mais il a forcément peut-être une
carte à jouer dernière chose il pèse
quand même 50 députés le groupe modemme
c'est 51 députés sur les 250 du du bloc
présidentiel ce n'est pas rien surtout
quand la la la course à la succession de
Macron va être lancé tiens justement
quand François baayrou dit à nos
confrères du Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France euh c'est c'est en c'est ce lundi
hein juste après sa relaxe en 2027 c'est
le centre qu' qui gagnera Jean Sébastien
Ferjou j'ai l'impression qu' qu' pense à
lui en disant ça est-ce qu'il rêve
est-ce qu'il a toujours un rêve
présidentiel François baayon je crois
que oui bien sûr mais ça été l'objectif
de sa vie il fait partie de ces grands
fauves politiques qui je pense ne
renonce jamais et c'est pas complètement
fou peut-être pas aussi fou que ça peut
y paraître même si Gabriel Atal
probablement aura tendance à ringardiser
assez vite je pense et Emmanuel Macron
et à forceie les générations qui qui le
qui le précèdent mais bien sûr qu'il y
pense après que passe-t-il réellement
parce que les 50 députés il les pèent
parce qu'il y a eu l'accord avec
Emmanuel Macron il les pèent pas parce
qu'il y a un ancrage il y a deux modems
d'ailleurs il y a un vieux modem avec
quelques vieux militants et puis il y a
des députés que François Baayou
d'ailleurs connaît assez peu lui-même
parce que ce sont c'est une nouvelle
génération qui est apparu en 2017 et en
2000 et en 2022 mais ces gens-là lui
sont-ils légitimes autant que ceux du
MoDem canal historique c'est une
question et par ailleurs est-ce que pour
être réélus ils ont besoin de François
baayerou où ils ont besoin d'un accord
avec le candidat qui serait le mieux
placé justement au centre je pense que
la réponse est plutôt qu'ils auraient
besoin de soutenir le candidat qui
serait le mieux placé au centre est-ce
qu'en l'état François baayerou est le
mieux placé non je suis pas certain je
je je reviens sur ce jugement vous
l'avez dit hein François Baayou relaxé
mais h autres condamnés dont l'ancien
ministre de la justice quand même Michel
Mercier et je rappelle que Marine Le Pen
et plusieurs cadres du rassemblement
national seront jugés pour des faits on
va dire similaires à l'automne la
justice est indépendante évidemment Jean
Garing mais quand même on se dit ça va
être un peu plus compliqué de condamner
l'ex-présidente du rassemblement
national il est vraisemblable que ce
jugement puisse faire jurisprudence par
rapport au jugement des leaders des
autres partis aussif d'ailleurs Marine
Le Pen et et éventuellement Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui sont sous le coup de
d'investigation et de procédures
similaires euh ce qui a été acté par la
relaxe de de de François berou c'est
qu'il y avait pas un système et que le
président du MoDem n'était pas au
courant de ce qui de ce qui se passait
ça on le saura on saura jamais euh
suffisamment l'idée de créer une banque
de la démocratie parce que le fond du
sujet et moi je le comprends c'est que
il y a beaucoup de difficultés pour les
partis à se financer moi trouvais que
les procédures en question était injuste
c'est un député de savoir ce qu'il veut
faire faire à ses collaborateurs
parlementaires non non c'est ça pose le
problème idée quand même parce que sinon
moins la proposition de banque de la
démocratie moi je je ne je je pas
préjuger de la chose a été jugée et
cetera mais en tout cas pour répondre à
la question effectivement il serait
assez logique que que cette
jurisprudence s'applique aussi à ceux
qui vont venir même si euh là encore il
y aura des il y a des investigations des
procédures il y aura un procès qui nous
dira ce qui ce qui en résulte pour pour
ce qui est de la situation de de
François Baayou j'ai un peu de mal à à à
croire que euh son son ambition
présidentielle puisse être intacte pour
pour 2027 parce que quand il nous parle
de d'une victoire du centre qui nous
parle peut-être de la victoire d'un
candidat qui représenterait le centre
droit et et le centre gauche et et d'une
nouvelle alliance qu'il pourrait
contracter parce qu'effectivement comme
ça a été dit ce qui a ce qui a permis au
au modem non seulement de se maintenir
mais de faire un bon spectaculaire
depuis 2017 faut quand même le le le
dire c'est le modemme était réduit à
quelques àel une poignée de députés et a
deux députés don don et Fran et François
Baayou donc il y a eu il a installé le
le modem et donc de façon assez assez
cohérente s'il advenait que le vainqueur
de 2027 soit un candidat venant de cette
nébuleuse du centre B il pourrait être
un partenaire de cette allez dernier
thme il nous reste moins de 5 minutes la
motion de censure déposée par les quatre
groupes de gauche à l'Assemblée
nationale a recueilli que 124 voil donc
largement rejeté monsieur censure contre
le Premier ministre évidem évidemment on
écoute le président du groupe PS à
l'Assemblée Boris Vallot qui lui dresse
un bilan désastreux des premières
semaines de gabrielzal il est là depuis
une semaine il a déjà un mauvais bilan
songeer qu'il a envoyé dos à dos la
question environnementale et la question
agricole finalement sacrifier l'avenir
au présent qu'il a augmenté de près de
10 % le tarif de l'électricité
prétendant être le premier ministre des
classe moyenne est en réalité celui des
Business Class il a supprimé
laallocation de
de solidarité plongeant dans la
difficulté un certain nombre de
travailleurs seniors qui sont exclus du
marché du marché du travail et puis tout
ça évidemment c'est renvoyé sur les
départements il a réussi le tour de
force de mettre les enseignants dans la
rue de faire démissionner le recteur le
recteur de Paris j'ai envie de dire non
je sais plus Stéphan zum je voudrais
qu'on fasse un focus sur le Gabriel àal
et la la colère des agriculteurs sa
gestion de laise de la crise agricole je
sais pas si ça a déjà été sondé si c'est
à mettre à son crédit finalement la
façon dont cette crise s euh quasiment
terminée en France bah il sen est plutôt
bien sorti en fait c'est c'était presque
une opportunité pour lui en plus le
président de la République était en Inde
à ce moment-là il prend très très vite
sa première crise crise qui pouvait
dégénérer enfin si le siège de Paris
avait été effectivement mise en place
les conséquences auraient été ne
serait-ce que politiquement très lourdes
il a bénéficié quelque part c'était une
opportunité pour lui et il a fait du
Gabriel Atal c'estàd ce qu'il fait
depuis qu'il est ministre de l'éducation
nationale c'estàd beaucoup de
communication mais se déplaçant tout de
suite très à l'aise on verra ce que ça
donnera dans lesffet après mais grâce
aussi à l'accord et la cogestion avec la
la FNS cette crise ben les agriculteurs
sont rentrés chez eux temporairement
peut-être on verra bien si les choses
reprennent au moment du salon de
l'agriculture mais il sort conforté de
ce qui s'est passé là encore il arrive
populaire et connu et cette crise n'a
pas entamé immédiatement en tout cas sa
popularité donc moi je trouve que c'est
c'est pas une victoire pour le
gouvernement c'est pas une victoire pour
Gabriel LAL en tout cas il n'a pas
laissé de plume dans cette crise jean-ar
cette motion de censure elle permet
aussi à Gabriel Atal de de compter ses
soutiens en en quelque sorte quelle
leçon vous en tirez oui bah c'est quand
même pas une surprise on s'attendait à
ce que cette motion de sension ne soit
pas à votter c'est très difficile ça
n'avait été voté qu'une fois sur la 5e
République le 5 octobre 1962 donc voilà
mais c'est vrai que c'est ça le renforce
plutôt par rapport à cette majorité mais
qui n'est qu'une majorité relative et
comme vous l'avez dit l'intention
aujourd'hui c'est de laisser plutôt le
le Parlement de côté et et de gouverner
par la le règlement donc on est dans
quelque chose de de de différent dans
une perspective différente et qui cadre
d'ailleurs avec la politique de de
d'action et de communication qui est
celle de de Gabriel hatal et qui
effectivement a plutôt pas trop mal
réussi me semble-t-il pour la gestion de
cette de cette crise agricole et donc là
il sort quand même de cette séquence là
plutôt renforcé je dirais pas qu'il a
gagné parce que on en est loin et que
les difficultés commencent mais il en
sort plutôt me semble-t-il consolidé on
va dire les LR n'ont pas voté cette
motion de censure Jean Sébastien Ferjou
vous parliez de leur leur réaction leur
colère potentielle face à un futur
éventuel débauchage on est on est
évidemment au conditionnel encore à à à
cette heur euh c'est une cartouche qu'il
se garde une cartouche à risque de voter
la motion de censure ben le risque c'est
surtout celui de la dissolution bah oui
et c'est surtout que se passerait-t-il
après quand on regarde la sociologie des
circonscriptions où sont élus les
députés LR pas forcment si menac que ça
pour imaginer qu' reste sur quelque
chose d'assz similaire quand on fait des
projections quand vous regardez en RALP
notamment la région de présidé par
Laurent voquier il y a un cœur
de députés LR qui vraisemblablement ne
serait pas menacé en Casti s offert un
sondage dans dans trois ou quatre
circonscriptions clés qui qui montre
prior effondrement de la majorité oui et
ça ser ça resterait favorable au députés
gagit pas non plus après je pense qu'il
y a deux phases il y a les élections
enfin il y a le calendrier des les
élections européennes jusqu'aux
élections européennes il y a un Laurent
vquier qui a décidé d'être en retrait
donc il n'y a pas d'incarnation très
claire pour les républicains il y a un
David lissnard qui travaille à
potentiellement devenir un candidat pour
la droite mais il n'est pas encore
forcément identifié par l'opinion et pas
en première ligne non plus et le
envoquer qui est en retrait après les
élections européennes c'est là où on
verra si elle est est vraiment dans un
cercueil Mathieu parlait tout à l'heure
le dernier C cercueil ou s'il y a un
espoir parce que l'opinion est quand
même assez largement justement droite
sur le territoire des républicains alors
après il le trouble totalement on a
entendu un ricoti notamment sur les
agriculteurs parler d'un revenu minimum
à 1500 € c'est quand même délirant dans
une famille de droite ben non les
agriculteurs ne veulent pas être
assistés ils veulent pouvoir vivre
dignement de leur travail mais bref
peut-être qu'un jour ils trouveront une
incarnation qui aura un peu plus de
panache merci à tous merci d'avoir
participé à ce premier débat jean- gar
votre livre jours heureux quand les
Français rêv ensemble et publiés aux
éditions
Paillot